waving flags they turned out in their
thousands to say goodbye to a man who
was never far from Scandal
as the cop in made its way into the
cathedral there was Applause
and in his speech the Archbishop of
Milan paid tribute to Silvio
berlusconi's passion for life
at this moment of leave-taking in prayer
what can we say of Silvio belusconi that
he was a man with a yearning for life
and love and a desire for joy
[Applause]
greens his supporters watched the
service
for them this was a chance to celebrate
a leader who dominated politics and
public life for decades
it was a great politician but rusconi
was everything it's someone that really
gave a lot to Italy and I'm I'm really
proud
with his permitanned smile Berlusconi
was for the world the face for many
years of Italian politics
he was a four-time prime minister but
controversy was never far away
Silvio Berlusconi was a polarizing and
divisive figure as prime minister he was
embroiled in numerous legal cases many
people thought he bought shame upon the
country but in death he has been
elevated now it appears a towering
figure of the Italian establishment
honored with a national day of mourning
an estate funeral
and even in death he is causing Discord
many Italians asking why such a
notorious man should be treated with
such reverence
he's a person that's in order to make
money and Achieve success ignored rights
people happiness and our future
what is not in question is that for
better or worse Silvia burlesconi was
without doubt one of Italy's most
influential politicians
his legacy is likely to be debated for
years to come
Alex Rossi Sky News Milan